Today, we'll talk about constraint propagation, another very drawn out purpose
method. Constraint propagation is a mechanism of influence where the agent
assign values to variables to satisfy certain conditions called constraints.
It is a very common method in knowledge-based AI, and there are a number of
different topics, such as planning, understanding, natural language processing,
visual spatial reasoning. Today, we'll start by defining constraint propagation.
Then we'll see how it helps agents makes sense of the world around it.
Our examples will come mostly from understand natural language sentences,
as well as visual scenes.
Finally, we'll talk about some advanced issues of constraint propagation.